hey guys Greg here I mentioned in my  passengers trailer review that I'm going  to be going to Switzerland for the  Zurich Film Festival they invited me to  go out there I'm really excited to go  it's a huge event a lot of big tymers go  a lot of current day big tymers go so  I'm very excited for that actually I hit  up by a flick flick flick flick flick  like John flixster he's going to be over  there too so we're going to meet up and  it's really exciting can't wait for him  to flex if you guys were wondering you  know why there might be a delay of  uploads or why things are dropping and  we're not covering it specifically it's  because I'm in Switzerland for the next  few days but when I get back we'll be  back to routine schedule